hey guys this is with maxtech we're here
at CES very excited to be here and we're
at the ring con booth now this is a very
innovated product it's a smart ring that
I'm wearing right now and we've actually
reviewed this in the past and I've used
it for many months on end and it's very
unique because it tracks all of your
health metrics including your sleep your
activity your stress levels and the nice
thing about it is that it has basically
5 to 7 Days of battery life and it does
work in the world it's lasted 7 Days on
end compared to like an Apple Watch
where basically dies after one day it's
not comfortable to wear when you're
going to bed this thing perfectly fine
and it actually tracks your sleep
perfectly well the stress levels I've
tested myself I've had stressful days
where the stress of a spike activity
everything it tracks it amazingly well
and the nice thing is that it comes with
this cool little charging base right
here that recharges you using USBC and
this will last probably 15 to 20 charges
and all you do is you stick your ring
inside of there recharges it within I
think probably a couple of hours and it
lasts 7 days really nice Innovation here
this ring is extremely durable it's made
out of lightweight titanium and it's
ip68 waterproof so you don't have to
worry about water or anything else and
they even sell a ring protector
separately if you want to cover it up
and keep that finish nice and clean for
long term it comes in three nice
finishes you have the gold the black
that I'm wearing and you also have
silver and you can see on the inside
that it's just lined and jam-packed with
a ton of sensors and my absolute
favorite part is that it comes with an
app that's subscription free which makes
it incredibly unique compared to other
Rings where you have to pay a monthly
subscription and you basically get like
a weekly data report or you can check
daily in real time all of your data your
sleep metrics everything it'll even
count things things like your steps your
heart rate your heart rate variability
blood oxygen saturation respiratory rate
and so much more and you can view it all
within the app subscription free it's
very very useful to kind of keep track
of your health and the reason you want
to track your health is because you
could actually make changes in your
daily life to adjust like for example I
notice that my stress levels actually go
down when I'm driving in my car
listening to music so actually applied
that to my life when I get stressed
stressed out now they also have a bunch
of new features as well the first one is
Wellness balance which basically gives
you an in-depth analysis of long-term
trends and short-term changes in your
sleep activity Stress Management Vital
Signs basically keeping you informed
about your daily physical activity and
mental health now one thing that's new
that's really exciting is the new
exercise mode which you could basically
turn on and you can get real time data
about your metrics and your vital
science during your workouts and on top
of that they also support CSV annual
exports you can basically get a rundown
of your entire Wellness kind of picture
and on top of that they're also working
on three features right now which is
sleep apnea monitoring menstrual cycle
monitoring for the ladies and sleep
coaching as well and even better all of
your data is private and secure and you
can even connect it to your Apple health
or your Google fit and synchronize with
all of your ringcon rings data so if
you're thinking about trying a smart
ring this is definitely the way to go
with the subscription free app that you
can use and basically I've been using it
and it's a really great experience I'd
highly recommend it and if you want more
in-depth information you can check out
our review that we made a few months
back definitely watch that video so here
we are ringcon it's been a great
experience here if you want to learn
more information use the links down in
the description and P and comment below
and we'll see you in the next video